-Simu, you're up first.
-Oh, no.
-Pull the mic
to spin the wheel.
-Oh, no.
-Let's see.
See what you'll be playing
tonight.
-[ Grunts ]
-Okay.
You got
Musical Genre Challenge.
-♪ Musical Genre Challenge ♪
-In this challenge, you're going
to get a song title
and a completely different
musical genre.
Then, you're going to have
to sing that song in that style.
Let's see what you get.
-[ Laughs ]
-"In Da Club," 50 Cent.
Bro Country.
-[ Laughing ] Bro Country?
-Whoo!
-"In Da Club."
You know 50 Cent.
-I know "In Da Club."
-"In Da Club."
-I like country.
-"Bottle full of bub."
The mic over there is yours.
-You guys realize I'm the only
non-professional musician here?
-Yeah. Yeah. That's what
makes the game fun.
-As long as that's clear.
Let's go, let's try it out.
[ Cheering ]
-Take me straight to Nashville.
Here we go.
-Let's go, baby.
All right, y'all.
Let's take it to Nashville
real quick.
-[ Laughs ]
-♪ Go, shorty,
it's your birthday ♪
♪ We gon' party like
♪ Gon' sip Bacardi
like it's your birthday ♪
♪ And you know we don't give
a -- it's not your birthday ♪
♪ You find me in the club,
bottle full of bub' ♪
♪ I got what you need
if you need to feel the buzz ♪
♪ I'm into havin' sex,
I ain't into makin' love ♪
♪ So come give me a hug
if you into gettin' rubbed ♪
♪ My flow, my show
brought me the dough ♪
♪ That bought me
all my fancy things ♪
♪ My cribs, my cars,
my clothes, my jewels ♪
♪ Look, homie, I done came up
and I ain't changed ♪
-Yeah!
-♪ It's your birthday ♪
♪ We gon' party like
it's your birthday ♪
-Yeah!
-♪ We gon' sip Bacardi
like it's your birthday ♪
♪ And you know we don't give
a -- it's not your birthday ♪
♪ You find me in the club,
bottle full of bub' ♪
♪ I got what you need
if you need to feel the buzz ♪
♪ I'm into havin' sex,
I ain't into makin' love ♪
♪ So come give me a hug if you
into gettin' rubbed ♪
♪ Go, shorty,
go, shorty ♪
♪ It's your birthday ♪
♪ Go, go ♪
♪ We gon' party like
it's your birthday ♪
-Oh, my God!
-Whoa, okay.
-Whoo!
-Oh, you saw that!
You saw that!
Oh, my God!
That is how you do it,
right there!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Simu Liu!
That's how you do it
right there.
[ Southern drawl ] Go, shorty.
It's your birthday.
We're gonna party, absolutely.